- Okay we have a passage here.
It says, "This passage
is adapted from a speech
"delivered by Congresswoman
Barbara Jordan of Texas
"on July 25, 1974, as a member
of the Judiciary Committee
"of the United States
House of Representatives.
"In the passage, Jordan
discusses how and when
"a United States president
may be impeached,
"or charged with serious
offenses, while in office.
"Jordan's speech was
delivered in the context
"of impeachment hearings against
"then president Richard M. Nixon."
So this is, this is fascinating.
Alright, let's start reading it.
"Today, I am an inquisitor.
"An hyperbole would not be fictional
"and would not overstate the solemnness
"that I feel right now."
That's a fascinating statement.
She's saying a hyperbole,
even an exaggeration,
really isn't an exaggeration.
It would not be fictional.
It would not overstate
how solemn she is feeling.
So she is feeling quite solemn.
She's taking this very seriously.
"My faith in the Constitution is whole;
"it is complete; it is total.
"And I am not going to sit here
"and be an idle spectator
to the diminution,
"the subversion, the destruction,
of the Constitution."
These are some serious words
here. Let's keep going.
"Who can so properly be the
inquisitors for the nation
"as the representatives
of the nation themselves?
"The subjects of its
jurisdiction are those offenses
"which proceed from the
misconduct of public men."
And they have this little asterisk here.
So it looks like if we
go to the bottom of it,
they're saying "Jordan quotes
"from Federalist" number 65,
"an essay by Alexander Hamilton
"published in 1788, on the powers
"of the United States Senate, including
"the power to decide cases of impeachment
"against a President
of the United States."
So once again, if we go
back to where we said,
this is a quote from
The Federalist Papers.
"Who can so properly be the
inquisitors for the nation
"as the representatives
of the nation themselves?"
So Hamilton's saying, hey look.
These are the people, you
know, these representatives.
These are the people who
can be the inquisitors
especially when the offenses proceed
from the misconduct of public men.
And that's what we're talking about.
Now this is her talking again.
"In other words, the jurisdiction comes
"from the abuse or violation
of some public trust."
So she's making an argument.
Look Congress has a voice here.
There's some violation
of the public trust,
so they are the appropriate inquisitors.
"It is wrong, I suggest,
it is a misreading
"of the Constitution for any member here
"to assert that for a member to vote
"for an article of impeachment
means that that member
"must be convinced that the President
"should be removed from office."
The Constitution does not say that,
or it "doesn't say that.
"The powers relating to impeachment
"are an essential check in the hands
"of the body of the legislature against
"and upon the encroachments
of the executive.
"The division between the two
branches of the legislature,
"the House and the Senate,
assigning to the one
"the right to accuse..." That's the House.
"and to the other the right
to judge - the framers
"of this Constitution were very astute.
"They did not make the accusers
"and the judges...the same person."
Fascinating.
"We know the nature of impeachment.
"We have been talking
about it a while now.
"It is chiefly designed for the President
"and his high ministers to
somehow be called into account.
"It is designed to 'bridle' the executive
"if he engages in excesses.
"It is designed as a
method of national inquest
"into the conduct of public men.
"The framers--"
She's quoting again from
the Federalist papers.
They have the asterisk there.
"The framers confided in the Congress
"the power, if need be,
to remove the President
"in order to strike a delicate balance
"between a President swollen with power
"and grown tyrannical, and preservation
"of the independence of the executive."
So there's a balance, that the president
is swollen with power
and grown tyrannical.
Hey, maybe that's an
appropriate time for impeachment
or even removal of the president.
But then you also have to preserve
the independence of the executive.
That's what the balance of power is.
"The nature of impeachment: a
narrowly channeled exception
"to the separation of powers maxim."
So once again, it's an exception
that typically the
president and the Congress
should be separate, but the Congress
starts to have jurisdiction
when the president
does something really over-the-top.
"The Federal Convention of 1787 said that.
"It limited impeachment to high crimes,
"to high crimes and misdemeanors,
"and discounted and opposed
the term 'maladministration.'"
So they're saying, hey look.
Impeachment isn't just
'cause you don't think
the president is doing a great job
or, you know, does something slightly bad.
It's for high crimes and misdemeanors.
High crimes and misdemeanors.
"'It is to be used only
for great misdemeanors,'
"so it was said in the North Carolina
"ratification convention.
"And in the Virginia
ratification convention:
"'We do not trust our liberty
to a particular branch.
"'We need one branch to check the other.'
"The North Carolina
ratification convention--"
So this is what they said:
"'No one need be afraid that
officers who commit oppression
"'will pass with immunity.'
"'Prosecutions of impeachments will seldom
"'fail to agitate the passions
of the whole community,'
"said Hamilton in the
Federalist Papers, number 65.
"'We divide into parties
more or less friendly
"'or inimical--"
Or inimical. Inimical. I always
have trouble saying that.
"'inimical to the accused.'
"I do not mean political
parties in that sense."
So in the Federalist Papers, hey you know
if there is a prosecution of impeachment,
people are going to
have opinions about it.
It's going to agitate the
passions of the whole community.
People are going to "divide into parties"
that are either for the impeachment
or against the impeachment
and hopefully not along party lines.
Just people who are sympathetic
to the impeachment or not.
"The drawing of political
lines goes to the motivation
"behind impeachment; but impeachment
"must proceed within the confines
"of the constitutional term
"'high crime[s] and misdemeanors.'
"Of the impeachment process,
it was Woodrow Wilson
"who said that, 'Nothing
short of the grossest offenses
"'against the plain law of the land
"'will suffice to give them
speed and effectiveness.
"'Indignation--'"
So this is kind of disapproval.
'"so great as to overgrow party interest
"'may secure a conviction;
but nothing else can.'"
So once again, the drawing
of political lines.
You know, obviously one party,
especially the opposing
party of the president,
they're gonna be the ones
that are gonna motivate,
be motivated to maybe start
impeachment proceedings.
But the indignation, the disapproval
of what the president has done
has to be great enough
to overcome party lines
in order to "secure a conviction."
So it can't just be,
or it shouldn't just be
one party trying to do
something political.
"Common sense would be revolted
"if we engaged upon this
process for petty reasons.
"Congress has a lot to do:
appropriations, tax reform,
"health insurance,
campaign finance reform--"
It's amazing.
They were talking about a
lot of this stuff in 1974,
and they still are.
"housing, environmental protection,
"energy sufficiency, mass transportation.
"Pettiness cannot be
allowed to stand in the face
"of such overwhelming problems.
"So today we're not being petty.
"We're trying to be big, because the task
"we have before us is a big one."
So she is taking this
very, very, very seriously.